so when the protests first erupted the
mayor of Olympia Washington was right
there with support even throwing her own
city under the bus
Cheryl Selby said her predominantly
white town was not as welcoming and
nurturing to minorities and the light
switched on by mr. Floyd's murder
now shines glaringly on Olympia but when
that light focuses on your actual house
the tune changes after woke vandals
damaged her home her predominantly white
town would suddenly victimized by what
she called domestic terrorism the
rioters had covered her front door and
porch with spray-painted messages it's
unfair she whined it's like the story we
cited after this all kicked off former
ESPN writer Chris Palmer deemed the
violent masses as animals and called the
cops on them as they neared his house
but that happened just after he urged
them to burn it all down while
retweeting a building in flames
low-income housing in Minneapolis
someplace far away but then the fire got
closer and Palmer felt the heat of his
own woke Ness
I'm not gonna say I told you so because
if you're listening you already know
that I'm just telling the truth it is
easy very easy to admire and even
encourage destruction when you're far
from it or well protected whether it's
defending riots or defunding cops the
loudest voices don't fret about the
consequences if celebs didn't have
private security they would be better
people because we know that if you
defend the police its minority
communities that will be hurt most but
if you're rich and powerful it's not
gonna touch you until it does just as
the mayor of Olympia who now sees terror
in her front yard maybe she can call the
Seattle cops they've got free time Jesse
now it's domestic terror how convenient
yeah well I had Victor Davis Hanson on
waters world over the past weekend he's
very smart near the IQ range of you Greg
I'd say top 20 maybe even 10% and he
said historically when you have
movements like this throughout the world
usually what puts a stop to them is when
they start eating their own and right
now you're kind of getting close to the
circular firing squad situation you know
they went after CNN headquarters they
even vandalized the afl-cio headquarters
now they're going to the homes of
Democrat politicians if they start
really targeting the media elite and the
political elite that's when they're
gonna shut this down it's kind of like
when the me2 movement everybody was all
in then they went after Joe Biden now
you don't believe all women anymore that
got shut down pretty quickly the one
thing I would tell these Democrats if
you don't want people vandalizing your
house build a wall very effective with
this stuff yeah yeah Emily this is
you're part of that your neck of the
woods are all of these leaders in
Washington just incredibly cowardly and
callow and naive and silly their
children yes they are and unresponsive
and delusional and ridiculous and
worthless mayor wheeler for example in
Portland he's such a joke to me remember
when he led Portland's ice building be
occupied for five weeks after which the
human excrement and needles were so
thick they had to have a hazmat team
come in to clean it and he was saying
during that time oh I'm not gonna let
the city get involved but pretty sure it
was the city's residents whose taxes
paid for that cleanup and these other
mayor Seattle mayor Durkin Olympia Mayor
Selby they are all the same they're just
performative allies they're songbirds
and to me they're in the same category
as those Hollywood Hills activists where
they say these delusional sound bites
from the safety of their snowflake homes
but when it really hits the fan then
they walk it back and as always like I
keep saying that the biggest losers are
those residents and I will say actually
the difference between these mayor's and
those Hollywood Hills activists is the
fact that these mayor's are having their
salaries paid by the citizens that they
keep letting down yeah Dana I am just
impressed that Emily has mentioned
excrement twice in this show already I
don't know if you did notice that you
used to use a word Greg used to like to
use a word that's
started with the letter P that meant the
same as excrement and maybe you wouldn't
have gotten in so much trouble with the
producers had you use the thesaurus of
the P word yes what I would just beat
Emily
that'd be yes that the mob giveth and
the mob taketh away
and now you have local leaders that are
realizing that I absolutely believe that
local government is the very toughest
government but you and it didn't get
this much that much attention and
probably didn't deserve to but not too
far here in the Jersey Shore and a Point
Pleasant Beach there's a mayor named
Paul quneitra and he had a situation
that just trashed the beach one Saturday
night and his response that he gave on
Facebook was so much different than
these other mayors that we're talking
about out in Washington State there are
some really good local elected leaders
out there we need people that want to be
in local government and if you're trying
to be a role of find a role model and
local government do not look to
Washington State look to somebody like a
Paul Quneitra yeah all right why take us
home well you know my take on this is a
little different than the rest of the
game because to me it comes down to one
point Americans have the right to
peaceful protest to a peaceful assembly
now defacing somebody's house that's not
peaceful assembly but the point is that
everybody has a right to go out and
protest to air their grievances their
protest in front of the White House on a
regular basis throughout American
history
that's the right of Americans it's in
the First Amendment for anybody who has
a doubt go check it out
and it goes down to the local level you
can protest so I'm hoping you're all for
that because that's what's going on and
I think I think by saying oh you're
going to demonize the protesters because
the mayor was supportive and then they
did something wrong their house they
were wrong but the protest isn't wrong
and give me a moment here because what
is
wrong is when you see for example these
white supremacists who infiltrate a
peaceful protest in Oakland and kill a
security officer at a federal building
or when you have the white supremacists
again interrupt a protest in Albuquerque
and kill a protestor that's what's going
on that's the pattern yeah and we should
call attention to it but the media
doesn't call as much attention to that
as it deserves yeah if